more and more businesses have been
wading into the referendum debate which
companies think prices will rise if
Scotland goes alone and more importantly
why do they think they will papi
Trowbridge is here with me probably who
have we heard from so far well the
business voices have been growing louder
of course the closer we get to the big
day next week these are some of the
consumer companies saying that their
prices could rise if Scotland decides to
go independent supermarkets you'll see
they're very concerned about one thing
and that is in particular higher
operating costs it's essentially like
running two homes it costs more than
running just one and this one won't
surprise you of course Sarah tax we yet
don't know what the different tax
regimes will be although one corporation
tax they're getting closer to the same
figure in the UK and in Scotland there
are many other taxes that affect
businesses and that's something they are
quite concerned about it's not just the
supermarket's is it well no today Sky
News has learned that a group of mobile
phone operators have been in talks about
issuing a statement along the same lines
they are concerned of course that they
will have to hike prices for their
customers because their prayer costs
themselves are going up and they cite to
further reasons one of them is of course
the customer base in Scotland would be
much smaller than in across the UK five
million people in that country 53
million people in the UK you miss out on
economies of scale of course yeah
absolutely and what are the reasons do
they come up with also that this one
really affects all groups whether we're
talking about the bank so the consumer
companies or the mobile regulators
they're very concerned about a new set
of rules a whole new regulatory regime
and in particular the mobile phone
companies and some of the consumer
companies are very worried about having
to pay for their industry regulator
that's always a big expense for business
it's our only chance though the prices
could actually go down well that's that
is possible I mean for example imagine
you sourced all of your groceries
locally and the supermarket's in
Scotland decided to focus on locally
sourced things your transport costs
could come down so you could see cheaper
products but of course you wouldn't get
as much choice you wouldn't have the
variety but it isn't inevitable that
costs
go up and in fact today Sky News heard
from another business leader who has
been very vocal about the fact that his
product the price of a pint could indeed
be cheaper in Scotland's chairman of
wetherspoons it will entirely depend on
the policies that the independent
scottish government follows if for
example they make v80 in scotland the
same as it is for supermarkets beer
prices may go down excise duty alcohol
duty in other words is much higher in
Britain than the average for Europe if
Scotland decides to make it the average
prices might go down so it will depend
on the policies that the Scots decide to
follow if they vote for independence
beer prices could go down might be a
popular one papi but there is still that
unresolved and vexed question of the
currency it's right here and the answer
to this question could be the first step
it has to be the first step in answering
all those other questions when we know
which currencies got them will take you
can start to do the maths and get to the
bottom of all those other issues okay
papi thank you